UNREAL.
CASEY, THANK YOU.
JOINING ME NOW LIVE FROM THE
BORDER TOWN OF SIERRA VISTA,
ARIZONA, SHERIFF MARK LAMB.
SHERIFF DANIEL, SHERIFF
CHILDRESS FROM ILLINOIS WELCOME
AND SHERIFF PAGE FROM NORTH
CAROLINA.
YOU ARE ALL WELCOME HERE,
SHERIFFS AND YOU ARE ALL WITH
THE PROTECT AMERICA NOW
SUPPORTING OUR SHERIFFS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
YOU HAVE A BIG JOB RIGHT NOW
AND YOU CAN GO TO PROTECT
AMERICA NOW.COM FOR MORE
INFORMATION.
EVERYBODY WATCHING WHEN THIS
INTERVIEW IS OVER AND LEARN
MORE ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE FACING.
LET'S GET A FIRSTHAND ACCOUNT
OF IT.
SHERIFF LAMB, YOU AND I TALKED
AS YOU WERE PULLING THIS GROUP
TOGETHER A WEEK OR SO AGO.
TELL ME WHAT YOU HAVE LEARNED
AT THE BORDER AND WHAT THE
PUBLIC IMMEDIATELY NEEDS TO
KNOW.
>> I THINK THE BIGGEST THING
WE'VE LEARNED WHICH IS WHY WE
HAVE SHERIFFS HERE FROM NORTH
CAROLINA AND ILLINOIS IS THIS
IS NOT A BORDER PROBLEM JUST
FOR ARIZONA OR TEXAS OR NEW
MEXICO OR CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS AN AMERICA PROBLEM T.
FACT THESE SHERIFFS CAME HERE
TO HELP US ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
SHOWS YOU THE IMPACT IT HAS ON
THEIR COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
>> Harris: SHERIFF DANNELS I
WANT TO ASK YOU A DIRECT
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT OUR
REPORTING WAS SAYING TALKING
ABOUT PUTTING CHILDREN IN
HARM'S WAY AND WHAT THEY'RE
SEEING IN TEXAS THEY'LL THROW
THEM RIGHT IN THE RIVER AND IT
DISTRACTS AGENTS.
HOW DIFFICULT IS THAT KIND OF
BEHAVIOR BY THE CARTELS TO
CURTAIL AND TO FIGHT IN THIS
WHOLE PROCESS?
>> WELL THANK YOU, HARRIS.
THANKS FOR HAVING US ON AND
THANKS TO MY SHERIFFS FOR BEING
HERE.
THIS IS THE LARGEST
HUMANITARIAN ISSUE ON THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
THEY ARE EXPLOITING THE PEOPLE
AND CHILDREN AND THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ASPECT AFFECTING ALL
COMMUNITIES IN AMERICA.
I WILL JUST SAY THIS, HARRIS,
TO YOU.
IN THIS REGION THE TUCSON
SECTOR OF BOARD ARE PATROL IN
THE FISCAL YEAR HAVE HAD 60,000
GETAWAYS JUST IN THIS SECTOR OF
THE BORDER.
THAT'S THE LARGEST IN THE
COUNTRY.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WE'VE SEEN ON
CAMERAS.
THEY HAVE GOT AWAY NOW IN
COMMUNITIES.
THAT SHOULD BE ALARMING TO
EVERY AMERICAN OUT THERE.
>> Harris: WHOA.
OKAY.
SO THAT BRINGS US TO SHERIFF
CHILDRESS AND PAGE.
SHERIFF CHILDRESS, YOU RST,
60 THOUSAND GETAWAYS FANNING
OUT ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT THE
BORDER.
>> GOOD MORNING, HARRIS AND
THANK YOU FOR SPONSORING US AND
THANK YOU TO THE SHERIFFS HERE
FOR HAVING ME.
YES, WITH NUMBERS LIKE 60,000
AND NUMBERS LIKE 172,000 COMING
IN, IT IS ABSOLUTELY LUDICROUS
THAT WE HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT REFUSES TO DO ANYTHING.
AND THEN LAST NIGHT I
UNDERSTAND THE STATE OF THE
UNION SPEECH THAT HE PUT IT ON
CONGRESS, YOU KNOW, SAYING THAT
HIS FIRST DAY HE ASKED THEM TO
SEND HIM A BILL.
WELL, WE'VE SEEN INSTANCES
WHERE WE HAD A PRESIDENT THAT
DIDN'T WAIT TO WAIT ON CONGRESS
TO PASS A BILL.
HE TOOK ACTION HIMSELF AND
THAT'S WHAT WE EXPECT A LEADER,
A TRUE LEADER TO DO, IS TAKE
ACTION.
WE SEE THAT WE'RE PUTTING LIVES
AT RISK, CITIZENS AT RISK,
BORDER PATROL AGENTS AT RISK.
IT IS JUST A RISK FOR EVERYBODY
AND THEN YOU BRING CHILDREN AND
THROW THEM IN THE RIVER AND
DROP THEM OVER THE WALL RISKING
THEM AS WELL?
>> Harris: SHERIFF PAGE I WILL
COME TO YOU NEXT AND I WANT TO
SHOW THE AUDIENCE SOMETHING
FIRST.
A RECENT FOX NEWS POLL FINDS
THAT NEARLY HALF OF PEOPLE
THINK THE BORDER SITUATION IS
WORSE THAN IT WAS TWO YEARS AGO.
56% MAJORITY BELIEVE BIDEN, THE
PRESIDENT, WINNING THE
ELECTION, IS COMPLETELY OR
MOSTLY BEHIND THE SURGE OF
MIGRANTS AT THE BORDER.
FIRST OF ALL, SHERIFF PAGE I
WANT TO GET AN IDEA YOU YOUR
TOP LINE THOUGHTS AND REACTION
TO THAT AND I HAVE A QUICK
FOLLOW UP FOR YOU.
>> FIRST OF ALL BEING FROM
NORTH CAROLINA I SEE NOW THAT
WE HAVE SOMETHING IN COMMON
WITH ARIZONA AND THIS IS REAL.
WE HAVE COYOTES LIKE THEY DO
AND MEXICAN DRUG CARTELS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THE VIOLENCE, THE CRIME, THE
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY ARE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND EACH DAY ACROSS NORTH
CAROLINA WE LOSE PEOPLE TO
HEROIN AND FENTANYL DYING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE KNOW WHERE THE PRODUCT IS
COMING FROM.
LIKE WE SAID WITH THE PRESIDENT.
MR. PRESIDENT, COME TO THE
BORDER.
MR. PRESIDENT, SUPPORT THE
LOCAL, STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACROSS TH
COMMUNITY AND DO SOMETHING.
ALSO, THE CARTEL WE DON'T
MENTION THEM A LOT.
BUT ILL OH HE TELL YOU THIS.
THEY ARE THE PERSONS MAKING THE
MONEY.
THE PERSON CAPITALIZING ON THE
HUMAN SMUGGLING AND TRAFFICKING
AND THE CRIME ACTIVITY AND THE
DRUGS THAT ARE TAKING LIVES
EVERY DAY IN AMERICA.
IF WE FAIL TO SECURE OUR
BORDERS EVERY SHERIFF IN
AMERICA WILL BECOME A BORDER
SHERIFF.
>> Harris: WOW.
SHERIFF LAMB I WILL GIVE THE
FOLLOW UP TO YOU ON THE NUMBERS
THAT WE JUST SHOWED OUR
AUDIENCE HOW PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
AT THIS AND SEEING IT GET WORSE
AND WHILE THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THE BIDEADMINISTRATION MAY
NOT WANT TO CALL IT A CRISIS
ACROSS THE BOARD, PEOPLE IN
AMERICA SEE WHAT'S GOING ON.
WHAT E YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> ABSOLUTELY THEY SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON.
WE HEAR IT EVERY DAY.
THEY ARE CLAMORING FOR OUR HELP.
I'M 70 MILES OUT THE BORDER.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS SAY THEY
CAN'T LEAVE THEIR KIDS TO WATCH
THE YOUNGER KIDS BECAUSE PEOPLE
TRYING TO OPEN THEIR DOORS.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS SITUATION.
WE AS SHERIFFS ARE STANDING
TOGETHER WITH PROTECT AMERICA
NOW, PLEASE CHECK IT OUT.
WE HEAR THE PEOPLE'S VOICES AND
WE'LL DO OUR JOB.
THEY DIDN'T HEAR WHAT THEY
NEEDED TO HEAR LAST NIGHT FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
WE EXPECTED TO HEAR MORE.
WE DIDN'T GET THAT FROM HIM.
THAT SHOWS YOU THIS PRESIDENT
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE BUT THE SHERIFFS
DO AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO STAND
UP FOR THE PEOPLE AND FOR
AMERICA.
>> Harris: I HAVE ONE FINAL
QUESTION TO YOU AND SHERIFF
DANELLES, THE MORALE ALONG LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS SOMETHING I'VE
HIT HARD DURING THIS HOUR ON
FOX NEWS.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT YOU FEEL
SUPPORTED.
I WOULD SAY EQUALLY SO FOR THE
BORDER PATROL AND WHY YOU ARE
THERE.
YOU ARE SHORING THEM UP.
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING THEY'RE MOST
DEALING WITH THAT YOU WANT TO
JUMP IN AND HELP RIGHT AWAY,
THE BORDER PATROL?
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT BECAUSE
THE MORALE, THE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS I SPOKE TO UP TO SENIOR
LEADERSHIP IS CHALLENGED RIGHT
NOW, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
THEIR HANDS ARE TIED FROM DOING
THE JOB, SECURE THE BORDER.
AND KEEP THIS COUNTRY SAFE.
AND WHEN YOU DO THAT YOU WILL
TAKE THE MORALE AWAY.
THE IMPACT ON LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND STATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS A COLLECTIVE
EFFORT.
AFTER LAST NIGHT'S SPEECH BY
THE PRESIDENT, IT WAS AN INSULT
FOR EVERYBODY WEARING A BADGE
TRYING TO PROTECT THIS BORDER.
>> Harris: SHERIFF LAMB FROM
LEFT TO RIGHT ON SCREEN, ALL OF
YOU SHERIFFS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SOME OF YOU COMING FROM FAR
AWAY TO THE BORDER TO GIVE US A
FIRSTHAND LOOK AND ALSO HELP.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME,
GENTLEMEN.
>> THANK YOU,